[Musique]
il était durant des décennies l'homme de
l'ombre de la communication des bleus
c'est lui qui pendant des années s'est
occupé de faire le lien entre les stars
de l'équipe de france de football et les
journalistes
un lien loin d'être toujours évident
aujourd'hui retraité de l'équipe de
france philippe tournon raconte dans son
livre la vie en bleu ce qu'il a vécu de
l'intérieur en immersion dans les
affaires sportives les plus médiatiques
de ces dernières années au contact de
ces champions qui fascine affaires
benzema la montée spectaculaire de
killian et mbappé enfant prodige ou
encore les révélations sur les matches
truqués qui tournons n'élude aucun sujet
et raconte ce qu'il sait sans filtre il
est ce soir avec nous pour tout nous
raconter sur les vrais coulisses du
football français merci d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup
vraiment c'est un honneur pour moi de
vous avoir et je voudrais dire
j'aimerais vous remercier parce que vous
avez fait vous avez beaucoup aidé et je
leur ai dit tout à l'heure lorsque il y
avait un jeune garçon qui voulait
absolument rencontrer paul pogba et vous
nous avez beaucoup m'aider et ça nous a
beaucoup beaucoup touché voilà je
voulais dire que c'était un rêve
incroyable pour ce garçon dont vous et
lui avait fait réaliser son rêve et
c'était en partie grâce à vous fini et
vous êtes vraiment un homme vraiment qui
nous a beaucoup aidés à chaque fois
qu'il y avait des problèmes ou des
joueurs ou voilà ou des trucs caritatif
vous étiez toujours présent pour nous
aider donc merci merci philippe alors
vous avez une carrière incroyable
puisque vous avez géré la presse des
bleus bas pendant pendant combien
d'années pendants je laisse en 37 matchs
en trente saisons 30 saison on est
content plus de trente ans après 30 ans
c'est incroyable vous êtes double
champion du monde eh oui peut-être le
seul nom didier 988 2018 bien entendu de
titres incroyables et pour votre
dernière conférence de presse les
joueurs présents avaient voulu vous
rendre hommage
- à peine regarder matuidi et antoine
griezmann riadh ben merci merci déjà
philips a fait moi je les ai connus qui
2010 mais que beaucoup de temps ensemble
et là il était parfois dur il a été une
part importante dans le le projet de
l'équipe de france philippe tournon
c'est sa dernière conférence
il est bon dans ce qu'il fait et voilà
même s'il a un peu grincheux et il
serait pas trop mais maintenant c'est
vraiment un chouette type est pas bien
chaud philippe messeiller vraiment je
vous dis quelqu'un qui a un grand coeur
et on l'a vu plusieurs fois en tout cas
avec moi ça vous fait quelque chose
quand vous voyez ces joueurs parler de
vous oui bah évidemment c'est que des
bons moments surtout que la conférence
de presse est terminée il ya 150
journalistes français qui sont levés qui
revient sur 10 quand l'émotion était
encore là quoi tant que j'ai pas été
trop mauvais dans mon job sans doute
alors vous avez écrit un livre
incroyable vous parlez de tout une des
affaires qui a fait le plus parler dans
le football ces dernières années c'est
le cas benzema lochois ans n'est plus
appelé en équipe de france depuis 2016
ça divise carrément la france 1 tout est
parti d'une histoire de sextape est ce
que pour y raconter à nos
téléspectateurs
c'est une affaire judiciaire au premier
premier degré c'est à dire qu'à un jour
au rassemblement équipe de france karim
benzema vient voir mathieu valbuena midi
couche secteur pétri dans une affaire de
de sextape et que l'on veut de faire
chanter moi j'ai peut-être une solution
pour toi j'ai quelqu'un tu veux qui
t'appelle tu veut l'appeler alors la
justice dira est ce qu'ils voulaient
vraiment rendre service à mathieu ou
comme karim le dis comme comme karim le
prétend il était du côté d'un de ses
copains qui connaissait les maîtres
chanteurs c'est pas établie du tout
toujours est il que les deux joueurs à
partir de ce moment là ce sont un peu
exclu
et après
[Musique]
les choses sont ce soit un peu calmée et
il ya eu des incidents qui ont fait que
didier n'a pas sélectionné karim et
scellier scellier à à une histoire de
l'avs
la non sélection de karim a entraîné de
la part d'eric cantona et d'autres
personnes des commentaires à connotation
raciste
alors c'est ça l'histoire narre faé ben
slema sont pas là c'est de par leurs
origines etc
c'est ce qu'on a dit parce que quelques
mois plus tard karim benzema donne une
interview en espagne dans laquelle il
sous-entend que didier deschamps il y
aurait cédé une partie raciste de la
france là et pas la maison même de
didier deschamps paraît-il il parie avec
le mot raciste voilà on arrive au bout
de la faire ouais
donc quand on a fait ces déclarations
karim benzema dit oui le sélectionneur
je dis pas qu'il est raciste mais il a
pu céder une partie de la population
française bien plus raciste et un jour
la maison des la femme de didier de
concarneau la maison des champs à
concarneau est taguée avec le mot
raciste et didier je l' ai vu ce jour là
très marqué je ne dis pas que karim ne
reviendra pas en équipe de france ça
seul didier peut le dire mais j'ai
l'impression que ce jour là une ligne
rouge a été franchie mais voilà est-ce
qu'il s'est expliqué un jour avec karim
à dire parce que je sais que didier
deschamps
comme vous l'avez dit a été très très
meurtrie 1 par cette histoire et part je
sais pas c'est que les gens ne savaient
pas s'ils ont bien parlé
on vous en avait parlé avec karim
benzema depuis deux ans je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion de gemmes pur comme ça il
paraît que didier deschamps aurait même
refusé de participer à l'émission au
tableau en 2018 à cause d'une phrase de
jamel debbouze sur didier effectivement
je raconte dans mon livre que l'émission
au tableau de mes listes et mélissa
theuriau saint-thuriau didier avait
donné son accord il avait commencé à
travailler avec alexandre darmon sur les
thèmes de l'émission va tous se
présentait bien et puis dans l'émission
qui précédait jamel debbouze a eu un
petit mot papa pas méchant homme enfin
est à dire si karim pouvait revenir en
équipe de france serait bien une vie et
m'a dit tu annules tout mais parce que
dis je crois que c'est une profonde de
la blessure il a dit aussi qu'il a été
meurtri de pas avoir d'explications
aussi avec didier deschamps
la trame urbaine c'est énorme malentendu
qui est parti d'une affaire judiciaire
et après les positions sont écartées
parce que je veux dire moi je connais
des deux bah c'est vrai que karim c'est
vraiment un mec que j'aime beaucoup
bien sûr je m'entends très bien c'est un
jeu didier deschamps données et didier
deschamps c'est un mec d'une simplicité
voilà qu'une la chance de rencontrer
bonne foi qu'est une famille très très
simple mais sa femme cdc avant d amour
mais serait donc c'est ça fait c'était
triste parce que je pense ça c'est parti
d'un malentendu et ça s'est envenimée
aujourd'hui les deux sons sont pénalisés
par ce qui se passe on voulait aussi
revenir sur la plus grande star du foot
français étaient bien sûr qu'il y avait
ma paix m bape est sûre si quelqu'un
pour qui la communication et vous
connaissez
lyon compte énormément quand il est
arrivé en équipe de france vous dites
dans votre livre il vous avez fourni
vous avez fourni un guide de dopage sur
comment gérer sa communication qu'est ce
que c'est pas c'est pas moi qui ai je me
suis procuré deux par un autre par un
autre canal mais il n'a pas eu
l'outrecuidance de dire voilà comment
faut il gérer voilà comment font
présenté voilà le décor mais
effectivement dans le extrême souci de
professionnalisme qui a entouré toute la
carrière de ce surdoué il y avait un
petit guide pour les interviews de 2 que
de quillanais mbappé s'il ya une musique
c'est sale et m a retenu convivialité
entre un vrai plaisir partagé pacy pas
savoir gérer par ses avocats n'ont alors
ses parents sont des gens remarquables
et gère sa carrière sportive sont
remarquables alors savamment et est
formidable aussi fait ça et wilfrid sont
des gens adorables et est représentée là
dans la carrière comment ils encadrent
killian depuis toujours et ils ont eu la
sagesse de confier à un cabinet
d'avocats tout ce qui était business
communication images et ces gens là très
professionnellement ont été dites et ce
petit fascicule certains en ont rigolé
moi je trouve que c'est très
professionnel
alors c'est vrai que voilà il maîtrise
tout que donc qu'il y a même battu et
c'est bon exemple du joueur qui est qui
qui est bien entouré un peu on a
l'impression d'être comme les cristiano
ronaldo comme elle aimait si c'est la
première fois qu'un joueur qui est aussi
au temps au tour et en france ou pas oui
avec ce souci du détail oui enfin
l'entourage peut aussi être très
favorables et positifs au niveau
familial ou des fastes d'antan dans
cette terre dans certains cas ou sinon
il ya eu des gens qui étaient mal classé
voit la part du golo rice et ses parents
il ya un encadrement familial y en a
quand une femme qui a les pieds sur
terre mais il y en a malheureusement
beaucoup qui viennent de milieux un peu
défavorisé l'argent commence à l'heure
tourner la tête
donc il ya des gens qui tournent autour
d'eux le conseiller image de conseiller
pour le patrimoine
ils vivent aux crochets du joueur ils
donnent pas toujours les bons conseils
si tu joues pas c'est ton entraîneur
c'est un connard et c'est ça qui
montrent aussi les joueurs je pense à
am j lac etc avec gan hemt yann m'vila
candidats voire 80 ou 100 sélections
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui s'est passé et
il y avait du monde beaucoup de monde
autour de lui qui donnait pas toujours
que des bons conseils et cic perdu en
chemin c'est un très bon joueur
cerexhe un exceptionnel en excédent et
réclame maintenant il a fait comme une
belle carrière oui puis revient bien il
assez sale enfin il aurait pu faire
beaucoup mieux prendrait alors il sait
pas qui des maps est celui qui vous a le
plus impressionné ces dernières années
où il fallait parmi la nouvelle
génération c'est le joyau parmi les
joyaux ousmane dembélé beaucoup de
talent il assurance maladie il embrasse
le frère aurait il ya beaucoup de
joueurs non là on a eu le avec martial
dembélé mbappé on a eu le génération
d'attaquants la crise mal trois ans
comme anne voilà c'est énorme
bien sûr c'est sa maman comme aït ali
comme m et alors non est ce qu'un joueur
voilà qui qui était vraiment voilà
puisqu'on parle souvent d'adil rami qui
était un joueur voilà qui m'était qui
était très important
mine de rien pour l'ambiance des bleus
est ce que c'est le joueur qui était le
plus sympathique en équipe de france
adil et tous sympathiques mais il ya des
2des tempérament réservé par exemple
raphaël varane va jamais mais mettre
l'ambiance quoi j'ai bien rigolé cette
façon c'est pas leurs amis ou franck
ribéry son époux bruno bellone pour la
génération 84 et aider des garçons qui
sortait des vannes à tout bout de champ
ou ribéry qui va tout dans ma crème
caramel aérola ancrée berry il a fait
des coupes des coûts jauger au buffet
prendre une crème caramel et il y avait
une âme ou tard c'est très serré
si c'est lui c'est dark pas voilà c'est
ici c'est vrai qu'il arrive pas c'est
franck ribéry la main jours il a pris le
volant du bus du bayern munich a passé
ici en plafonner le pourrai alors dans
votre livre revenu aussi sur un autre
dossier alors y'a plein de dossiers on
peut pas revenir sur tout ce soir mais
c'est vrai que ce livre est incroyable
un philippe tournon la vie en bleu 50
ans de secrets dans les coulisses de
l'équipe de france chez albin michel et
vous revenez sur les matches truqués sur
la triche dans le football et ça c'est
un passage extrêmement intéressant en 97
on se rappelle que bernard tapie était
condamné à deux ans de prison dont huit
mois ferme dans l' affaire de match
truqué entre valenciennes et l'om des
joueurs de valenciennes déclaré avoir
été à 93,93 exactions ou aurait été
invité par des émissaires de l'équipe
adverse a levé le pied en échange d'une
somme d'argent
une peine de prison pour des matches
truqués pour vous c'est normal je suis
pas juge l échelle d'appréciation le le
procureur de montgolfier et qui était au
coeur ric de la faire a reconnu
récemment que ça valait peut-être pas ça
le problème c'était que le personnage
central c'était bernard tapie a fait du
tapis dans les grandes largeurs
montgolfier a pas du tout aimé et il a
été extrêmement sévère sortie de l'anti
tapis quoi ce qu'il va faire mais tapie
était arrivé il lui a dit carrément bon
peut-être qu'on peut s'arranger enfin il
montgolfier raconte ça on devine un peu
que ça a dû se passer comme ça donc il
n'y a pas fait de cadeaux visiblement
mais ça vaut peut-être pas ça le faisait
pour les matches truqués il y en a pas
ma connaissance il n'a pas eu quand même
le football français n'est pas gangréné
parle alors les matches truqués
il ya quand même dans la veine des
signes il ya eu président de
saint-etienne qui passe aussi par la
prison pour une affaire de caisse noire
noire
le président de bordeaux pour des
pratiques frauduleuses mais aussi des
histoires de corruption qui ont bousculé
et qu'on voit là la fifa ou l'uefa dans
les autres pays que la france ya
beaucoup de matches truqués ou pas oui
il ya des pays où on cite souvent là la
turquie à la fifa suspendu des
fédérations pour les des pratiques un
peu à peu douteuse
je pense que pas décerner un brevet
d'exemplarité à la france mais je pense
qu'on est quand même pas mal au point de
vue
rigueur alors derrière d'ailleurs il y
en a certains qui ont même été jusqu'à
soupçonner que la finale de la coupe du
monde 90 des cas j'ai pas vu ses sorties
parce que c'était en france il ya plein
de gens qui s'étaient acheté vous avez
déjà prévu que le brésil est en finale
en fait ce que disent les gens philips
et qui disent que le tirage au sort même
depuis le tirage au sort après senna
c'est n'importe quoi
mais il y en a qui disent que même le
tirage au sort est arrangé que tout
avait été fait pour qu'il y ait une
finale mais séquence facile mais c'est
comme ça dans toutes les coupes du monde
précédentes le le pays organisateur est
placé comme en tennis de table puis le
gbp attendrissant l'autre bout c'est ça
c'est pas c'est pas de la magouille
c'est pas du favoritisme et ses coques
federer et nadal quand il était numéro
un et on ne compterait pas exactement
voilà c'était c'était pareil voilà alors
c'est vrai que ça c'était ci peut pas
voir tu voyais pas truqué les deux buts
de thuram en demi finale contre la
croatie 20 truc assez inquiet thuram qui
marque du gauche passe qui faire quoi
troisième question on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup plus d'argent aujourd'hui dans
le foot qu'il ya 30 ou 40 ans est-ce que
tout cet argent le foot business est
responsable de toutes les polémiques que
vous évoquez est ce qu a trop d'argent
dans le foot nord l'argent l'argent
n'est pas condamnable argent dans le
football business c'est de l'argent
privé
c'est une activité qui génère des
milliers d'emplois et qui reverse en
taxes et en impôts des milliards au fisc
français
donc en revanche pour rester dans
l'actualité du moment et le football
français a voulu se croire à l'égal de
l'espagne de l'italie de l'angleterre et
l'espagne
on n'y est pas et vous savez c'est que
les joueurs devraient baisser leur
salaire avec l'actualité
donc dans le contexte actuel et le
marasme où sont les clubs à geste des
joueurs serait le bienvenu mais personne
ne peut les obliger
ils sont sous contrat individuel mans
avec les clubs certains vont le faire
d'autres le feront géraldine qu'il est
vous parlez de la communication des
joueurs et comme vous êtes une sorte de
mal à disque dur de cette récréation
je voulais savoir est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas quand même nostalgique de la
communication d'avant ou alors on
s'extasie sûr qu'il y avait ma paix mais
vous pensez pas que ça manque quand même
de spontanéité et de fraîcheur
rappelez-vous à l'époque de les yeux
dans les bleus oui voilà aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez que les réseaux
sociaux complètement changé là
anne mais ont changé même votre maîtrise
il a lyon ils ont changé la donne mais
si elles sont sous la pression
médiatique moi je raconte dans mon
bouquin que les stages de l'équipe de
france au début des années 70 on était
six ou sept
aujourd'hui ils sont 150 alors si souci
était à l'époque chef de presse pour
nous emmerder
on monte dans les délais le photographe
de l'équipe le rappel d'aider le coq tu
étais le photographe star de l'équipe et
à la sortie de l'entraînement et déjà
beretta révelli loubet tiens je t'emmène
il est moitié en voiture dans le vieux
saint malo il les mettait à califourchon
sur les cas monde sur coup il faisait la
photo pour la une de l'équipe du
lendemain ces voix là aujourd'hui mais
on reste à organiser des photos cc de
galère tous les composants mais aussi
c'est qu'il joueurs c'est qu'ils joueur
qui vous a le plus marqué à la question
à quel point de vue j'ai pas le premier
joueur qui va d'expression plus sympa
celui qui avec qui vous entendiez de
quatre histoires que vous êtes moins 18
j'ai toujours eue quand j'ai débuté
c'était la tradition l'équipe le petit
dernier rentrée s'occuper de l'équipe de
france junior et dans l'équipe de france
juniors de 68 qui a été en finale de
championnat d'europe y avait un joueur
exceptionnel
serge chiesa était d'avesnes de platini
de zidane au point de vue ballons point
de vue de toucher de balle mais le petit
gamin il voulait pas les stages il
voulait rester à la maison avec sa
petite femme son petit chat sa cheminée
et il a refusé l'équipe de france les
fleurs des stades mais au point de vue
talent ce gamin c'est vous pouvez faire
une carrière à la halle à mais s'il
enrage un petit kit pensez vous êtes ça
doit les faire plaisir en club simon
leys celle ci donne zidane ou web apps
est très différent très très différents
dans le jeu dans le tempérament le
joueur zidane était d'une timidité
c'est vrai que c'était lui le vrai
patron de l'équipe de france en 98 le
patron technique oui ouais mais c'est
tagro même c'était deschamps l'ont
vraiment des chambres et chantepie
laurent blanc en deuxième rideau et
après après avec quand il ya eu raymond
domenech la sphère du match et pas il
n'était pas allé quand raymond et à vire
est arrivé il a virtuellement donc j'ai
pas connu cette époque pas trop
le plus de talent tu as dit celui le
plus car ce casque bisons qui ferait
plus de mal à donner beaucoup de mal
mais vous savez jamais comment ça allait
tourner c'est eric cantona un gars
adorable un tempérament entier mais il a
sans comment dire son sens de la justice
à lui quoi il faut que ça rentre dans
ses tous les joueurs ont un moment sont
fait insulter par des supporters en
passant mais ils sont pas tous été le
plus décodeur c'est ribéry ouais la
palme pour faire bien et bien merci en
tout cas philippe tournon on va rappeler
à vos clics je sais qu'on aurait pu
rester des heures 1 avec vous la vie en
bleu philippe tournon 50 ans de secrets
dans les coulisses de l'équipe de france
chez albin michel
très très très bon ouvrage merci
philippe ça m'a fait plaisir
[Applaudissements]